[Music]
ursula kayla green's second earth sea
novel the tombs of ottawa does not
actually begin in the narrative itself
with talk or depiction of the ring of
arith akba
but that's going to be in a sense the if
we look at the narrative world the
pretext for there being
any story at all
in part because ged one of the
characters in the story the main
character from the previous novel
and arya
later tenar
the priestess of the nameless ones at
the tombs of otto and would not have
become connected
if ged had not come to the kargish isles
to seek out the missing half of the ring
and so in a way you can't have the story
without having the ring and the ring
assumes very central importance
as one of the thematics
of the story as well
the first mention of it is when the
older women thar and castle
are telling arja about
the world and about things that she
should know from being the
previous priestess and the one before
her
reincarnated as this child it says it
still made her feel strange when thyron
castle spoke to her of things she had
seen or said before she died she knew
that indeed she had died and been reborn
in a new body at the hour of her old
body's death not only once 15 years ago
but 50 years ago and before that so
what are the things that are being
talked about one of the key things is
this story
and thar and castle
tell her many came to rob the tombs long
ago but none ever did so
how would any man dare
they would dare castle said they were
sorcerers wizard folk from the inner
lands that was before the god kings
ruled the target lands we were not so
strong then the wizards used to sail
from the west to karego at and otto on
to plunder the towns on the coast loot
the farms even come to the sacred city
abawath they came to kill dragons they
said but they stayed to rob towns and
temple so we have wizards and heroes
coming from the west to the kargish
lands right
and they are
not just doing the task that they say
they're supposed to be doing they are
coming into a place that's disunited
politically and perhaps vulnerable to
them they have powers that the cards
don't uh have or want or respect powers
of sorcery also uh as she goes on to say
their great heroes would come among us
to test their swords so there might have
been some
advantages in brawn or technology or
things like that and what we've got here
is an invasion or at least
adventuring in these kargish lands and
essentially you know mixing up in their
politics
and uh despoiling them and and all of
that so
this is part of the backstory now is
this completely accurate well we don't
really know because it's being told by
a carnage priestess so perhaps it
represents their point of view more it
might be more complicated than that but
this is the backdrop and against that
backdrop she goes on and says one of
them a mighty sorcerer and dragonlord
the greatest of them all
came to grief here
it was long ago very long ago but the
tale is still remembered and not only in
this place the sorcerer was named aerith
akba and he was both king and wizard in
the west and we'll learn more about him
in the later books and a little bit more
about him in in the stories that as gad
is going to tell as well but so arith
akba is somebody at the pinnacle of
power and prestige and perhaps even
knowledge in earthsea
and he he comes to the kargash lands and
he gets mixed up in the politics there
as they say he joined with certain
kargish rebel lords and fought for the
rule of the city with the high priest of
the inmost temple of the twin gods in
ahwabath so that's kind of a big deal
right he's trying according to them
trying to take over
one of the main cities and he's fighting
with this other person who's at the
pinnacle of power this high priest whose
name is in tothan who's going to become
the
progenitor of an entire lineage of high
priests and then eventually to the god
kings who are in um you know that their
apex of power at the time that this
story is being told and the god kings
are kind of you know they've reunited
the kargash lands and they're also
essentially replacing the other
power structures in the land as we're
going to see now the story about the
ring right here we go
long they fought the man's sorcery
against the lightning of the gods the
temple was destroyed around them at last
the high priest broke the sorcerer's
witching staff
and broke in half his amulet of power
and defeated him he escaped from the
city and from the kargish lands and fled
across earth sea to the farthest west
and there a dragon slew him because his
power was gone since that day the power
and might of the inner lands has ever
waned so at the time that we're looking
at this story the kargish lands are able
to raid you know gaunt as they did in a
wizard of earth see in some of the other
western isles
so his the the staff the wizards staff
which is part of the power of the wizard
of ereth akbar is broken and even more
important his amulet of power the ring
of arith aqba is broken and what happens
to it then well there's there's two
sides to this broken ring and the high
priest
in tathan gives his half to the treasury
of the tombs the tombs of ottawa the
nameless powers and what we find later
on in the story is that this is in the
very inmost part of the labyrinth the
thing that that ged is is seeking and
that so many others have sought as well
eric akbar
gives his half to
a king and
he's described by castle in kind of a
derogatory way
here we go
uh he's given to a petty king one of the
rebels named thorig of hoplin
and he says
we don't know why he did so and castle
says to cause strife to make thorig
proud and so it did the descendants of
thorig rebelled again when the house of
tarb ruled and yet again they took arms
against the first god king refusing to
acknowledge him as either king or god
they were an accursed ensorcelled race
they are all dead now thar nodded the
family of our present god king the lord
who has arisen put down that family of
hapon and destroyed their palaces when
that was done the half amulet which they
had kept uh ever since the days of eric
eric akba and
interthin was lost no one knows what
became of it and that was a lifetime ago
so this is setting the stage right this
is arya learning about uh some of the
lore of of her time and then what do we
find many thieves and wizards come to
ottawa to seek the half ring it's
something that draws people in and the
latest of them
is get
so we find
that there's uh here we go
she's looking into the
through these peepholes into
the inner chambers under the the tombs
and she sees something she sees
a light then she sees
a person
right and
she tells herself
what must i tell castle nothing not yet
i am mistress of the labyrinth this is
no business of the god kings i'll tell
her after the thief is dead how must i
kill him
right and then she says how did he get
in well only a sorcerer could do it and
she stops and she thinks she's actually
in the
under uh tombs themselves
he's a sorcerer
a wizard of the inner lands seeking the
amulet of arith akbar
so before she was being told the story
now
she's suddenly in the story right as the
priestess of the nameless ones
and now there's
a sorcerer a thief trying to come in
ged is a little bit different
in that he is actually coming in
with
the missing half
and when he's
captured right she has her eunuch
manon with her he's um succumbing to
thirst and hunger and the psychological
pressure the magical pressure of the
nameless ones and their anger at his
sacrilege
she's uh she she takes the thing from
him
she's uh here here's how it goes
where's his staff man on there i'll take
it it has magic in it oh and this this
i'll take two
with a quick movement she sees the
silver chain that showed at the neck of
the man's tunic and tore it off over his
head though he tried to catch her arms
and stop her monon kicked him in the
back she swung the chain over him out of
his reach is this your top your talisman
wizard
is it precious to you it doesn't look
like much couldn't you afford a better
one i shall keep it safe for you and she
slipped the chain over her own head
hiding the pendant under the heavy
collar of her wood woolen robe you don't
know what to do with it he said very
hoarse and pronouncing the words of the
kargish tongue but cleanly enough and
what we have here is in fact the other
half
of the ring not
said so as such at that point but we're
going to see
as the story goes on it gets revealed
as such right there's a discussion in
chapter 7 as they're in
the the room um moving you know uh
towards the the ring where they talk a
little bit about um
eric akbar she says who was he and he
says
it's true you would know little of him
here nothing beyond his coming to the
kargish lands how much of that tale do
you know he she says he lost his
sorcerer's staff in his amulet and his
power like you he escaped from the high
priest and fled into the west and
dragons killed killed him but if he come
here to the tombs there had been no need
of dragons and then she she changes the
topic she doesn't want to talk about
earth aqua
eventually
they
talk about the ring again
and this is at a time of crisis after
she's regained her name and they're
beginning to
develop this this thing that ged will
identify as trust
so he tells her
that i found what i was after
she says the ring the half ring
you have the other half the talisman
that she took from him was in fact the
missing half that had gone to the other
kargish lord
while he was in the treasure room he
found the one thing that he cared about
the missing other half of the ring that
had been buried
for
centuries perhaps millennia
so he says um
you took it off and asked me if i
couldn't afford a better talisman the
only talisman better than the half of
the ring of ereth akba would be the
whole but as they say a half a loaf
better than none so now you have your
half
and i have yours you have my half and i
have yours he smiled across the shadows
of the tomb you said when i took it i
didn't know what to do with it that was
true and how do and you do know he
nodded
so she says tell me what is it the ring
and how you came on the lost half and
how you came here and why
and so
he tells her two things what is the ring
itself
and how did he come into possession of
the ring how he came into possession
that's a story that we find out in a
wizard of earthy and recapitulates
itself here
he says that
when i was a little older than you i was
on a chase
that which i hunted tricked me so i was
cast up on a desert isle not far off the
coast of karagoat and ottawa south and
west of here it was a little eyelet not
much more than a sand bar yet two people
lived there an old man and a woman a
brother and a sister
they had not seen any other human face
for how long years tens of years but i
was in need and they were kind to me
and she he goes on and says
we couldn't talk i didn't know the
kargish tongue then and they knew no
language of the archipelago they must
have been brought here as young children
and left to die i don't know why in
doubt that they knew they knew nothing
but the island the wind and the sea but
when i left
she gave me a present she gave me the
lost half of the ring
of aerith aqba i didn't know it for what
it was no more than she did the greatest
gift of this age of the world and it was
given by a poor old foolish woman in
seal skins to a silly loud who stuffed
it in his pocket and said thanks and
sailed off well i went on and did what i
had to do but all the time i kept the
thing with me because i felt a gratitude
towards that old woman who'd given me
the only present she had to give i put a
chain through one of the holes pierced
in it and i never thought about it and
then one day on celador the farthest
aisle the land where ureth akba died in
his battle with the dragon orm on
cellador i spoke with a dragon one of
the lineage of orm he told me what i
wore on my breast
so he learns that about the nature of
the ring and he tells her a little bit
earlier what is this the ring of earth
aqba it's not precious looking it's not
even a ring it's too big an arm ring
perhaps
no one no man knows
who it was made for elfer on the fair
wore it once before the isle of soleil
was lost beneath the sea and it was old
when she wore it and at last it came
into the hands
of areth aqua so he didn't create it it
was just the ring he happened to have
the metal is hard silver pierced with
nine holes there's a design like waves
scratched on the outside and nine runes
of power
on the inside the half you have bears
four runes and a bit of another mine
likewise the break came right across
that one symbol and destroyed it that's
the lost rune the other eight are known
to mages
he tells what they are that the broken
ruin was the one that bound the lands
the bond room the sign of dominion the
sign of peace no king could rule well if
he did not rule beneath that sign no one
knows how it was written since it has
been lost there have been no great kings
in hovnor there have been princes and
tyrants and wars and quarreling all
among the lands of earthsea so
there had you know some sort of unity
was lost when this ring was broken and
that rune was no longer able to be
repeated
he goes on and he says the wise lords
and mages of the archipelago wanted that
ring back that they might restore the
lost rune but they gave up sending men
to seek it since none could take the one
half from the tombs of ottawa and the
other half which ereth akbar gave to a
kargish king was lost so it was you know
seemingly an impossible feat
ged takes it on because he has the other
missing part of the ring
and in the story
the ring is restored
tenar
or ara makes a choice to trust get
to bring the rings together
and then he
through magic
is able to fix the ring
um
here we go this uh she she says you've
uh uh
she gives him the the uh broken talisman
and he says you've set us both free
alone no one wins freedom let's waste no
time hold it out again for a little she
closed her fingers over the pieces of
silver but at his request she held them
out on her hand the broken edges
touching he said a couple words sweat
suddenly sprang out on his face
ged's side his tent stacks st 10 stance
relaxed and he wiped his forehead there
he said in picking up the ring of arith
aqba he slid it over the fingers of her
right hand there he regarded it with
satisfaction it fits it must be a
woman's arm ring or a child
will it hold she murmured nervously
it will i couldn't put a mere mending
charm on the ring of ereth akba like a
village witch mending a kettle i had to
use a patterning a magic that goes to
the depth of the realities and make it
whole it's whole now as if it had never
been broken
and so that is
what happens
and we get to the very end of the story
as he says the story comes whole
even as the ring is made whole but it is
a cruel story tenar
the little children the isle the old men
and women i saw they scarcely knew
human speech what happened to them well
we find out the rest
of the story
of the ring
i was told the tale
it is part of the knowledge of the first
priestess this is this is our tenor at
this point thara told it to me first
when consul was there
then more fully
when we were alone it was the last time
she talked to me before she died
there was a noble house in huppin who
fought against the rise of the high
priest in abuath the founder of that
house was king thorig and among his
treasures he left his descendants was
the half ring which aerith akba had
given him
god says that indeed is told in the deed
of arithma it says in your tongue it
says when
the ring was broken half remained in the
hand of the high priest and half in the
hero's hand and the high priest sent the
broken half to the nameless to the
ancient of the earth in ottawa and it
went into the dark into the lost places
but eric akbar gave the broken half into
the hands of the maiden tirith daughter
of the wise king saying let it remain in
the light in the maiden's dowry let it
remain in this land until it be rejoined
so spoke the hero before he sailed to
the west
and then tenor responds
so it must have gone from daughter to
daughter
or this guy of that house over all the
years it was not lost as your people
thought but as the high priest made
themselves into the priest kings and
when the priest kings made the empire
and began to call themselves god kings
all this time the house of thor grew
weaker and weaker and so
at last so thar told me there were only
two of the lineage of thorig left little
children a boy and a girl the god king
in abuth was the father of him who rules
now
he had the children stolen from their
palace and happen there was a prophecy
that one of the descendants of authoric
of huppin would bring about the fall of
the empire in the end and that
frightened him he had the children
stolen away taken to a lonely aisle
somewhere out in the middle of the sea
and left there with nothing but the
clothes they wore in a little food he
feared to kill them by knife or
strangling or poison they were of kingly
blood and murder of kings brings a curse
even on the gods they were named enzyrin
on phil it was on the who gave you the
broken ring and so what we see in this
story
being told and brought to a close is a
mirroring of the ring itself
being restored we have all of these
pairings all of these
broken things being brought back
together
and among them are the two who have
agency as characters
ged and arha who has regained her name
of tenor
you